it's not currency
but fruit and veg they trade here
this green Grocers is in Derbyshire but
what happens on International money
markets matters here
as the pounds value has dropped the
price of diesel and petrol linked to the
dollar is Rising once again
and they've got deliveries to make fuel
prices have been hiked for quite a while
now and we've been banking on them going
down as we do a lot of deliveries over
quite a large area so it has had a real
impact on us we've we've really tried to
absorb the costs right through how long
we can save off you know putting up the
delivery prices as you know it's it's
coming to the country really
crunch time too for some Industries like
craft beer makers hit so hard by covered
lockdowns
beer hops are imported from the United
States and overnight they've become up
to 20 percent more expensive that's on
top of other Rising costs from energy to
many raw materials
I know that we are completely up against
it we've got nowhere left to turn no
more savings to make other than
redundancies and scaling the business
down if this crunch persists if this
fall in the pounds value persists for
more than uh more than just weeks I
think the industry is in Dire Straits
ultimately this could mean higher prices
as consumers we can try and cut back
spending to a degree but there are
simply some unavoidable costs we've
already seen the impact that the
dropping pound has had on mortgages but
that isn't just something which affects
people who own homes but renters as well
and that could affect millions of people
some have already seen their monthly
rent go up I don't claim benefits any
money that comes into my house is my
wage but with the wage that I'm getting
I should be able to afford a car I
should be able to afford to look at
maybe putting a deposit on a house I
can't save money right now and as for
doing things with the children and you
know if they want additional treats or
they need clothes or things for school
as well you just can't do it
the falling pound means Rising pressure
and uncertainty about how to cope
Z's Sky News in Manchester